RIGHT N TEXAS, WASS NEW
YORK ASHE THIRDUS CASES IN
COUNTRY.
WE KNOW THAT G BE ON
FORCENE TRAVELING WES TESTEDTLI.
HE TESTEOS F PUBLIDISMISSIVE AB
AND WAS WALKING WITH
TOR
CATONEITHER OF THEM WEARINGPERI
JERE DW. LEA NOW ABOUT
PUMP WHO HAS ALSO TESTED
POSITIVE FOR THE VI Reporter: T,
AND, HEREAS LONG
DOUBLE STANDARD AS IT RELATES
PRESIDENESTING.
HE HASAM THE AMOUN OF  TO SLOW
DOWN TESTING WHILE AT SA
TIME HAVING ONE OF
ROBUST TES PROTOCOLS AT THE
WHITE T TESTINGROTOCOL
HASVEOT TWO
ET TO BE
WITH THE PRESIDENT TODAY F
BEINN PRESENC A
TE CONTAMINATING HIM CORONAVIRU.
IN ADDITION TOONGRESSMAN LOUIE
GOHMERT WE ARE ALSO LEARNING
AT NT
CANDIDATE FORVENTH
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT ALSO
TESTED POSITIVE AS HWAY TO TPO
CONCERNED, JAKE, IN ADDITI T WER
TS HOW
LICANESSDLY RE W
ES POSIT
HO BEFORE HE WAS
JOIN PRESIDENT ONIR
FORCE ONIDN'T HAVE ANYE
MPHAT YOU LISTED F COVIRUS. CGR
WALKRGENERAL
BIAR H DIAGNOSIS
AT THETES MNI GOHMEIALYISOLATE .
INSTEAD, RUR
RETIFFICEO TE STAFF PERSON.
SOME MEM ERTAFF
TELLING "POLITICO" TRESSMAN WOUG
>> ABOUT BEHAVIOR OFOFHE REPUBL
AN R ISN'T
NGHEISDEFIANFDELINES MAY
PLAYED I CONTRACTINGTHE.EA BLA
CE.
>> IHE WEEK OR TWO,
HAVE WORN IN THE LAST FOU. HELP
KEEPING A MASK ON ANDT
IN PLACE THAT IF MIGHT'VE
GERMS, SFHE MASK AND BREATDIN.K.
>> Reporter: AS FNC AWAY FRORELY
BUT  I FOCUSED ON
CIENTIST
OVERWHELNG ANCTIVE CORAV
S VIRUS ACURE.
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINENC.
ep
VI A FRINGE
BOGUS CLAIMS ABO
HYDROXYCHLOROQ, ISKING BY HIS P
SPECTACULAR IN HER STATEMENTS
ABOUT.ter: EVEN SHE WAS
B
CLAIEN DNA SEX
DEMONS I THINK SHE MADE SENSE, I
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
I JUSTSHE IS A VESPECTED DOCTOR
ISN'T JUST WATCHINGCE PRESIDENT
HEHE
DOCTOR BELON T BRANDED AS
AMERICA'S FRONTRS
PROPPED UP BY THETHE WHHO
TO DCUROQUINE.
N ARE TREAT PATIENTS ON
THE FRONTES .ANTHONY FAUCI ONCE
REMINDING THE PUBC
HYDROXYCORWORK.
>> BUT TODAY
CUMULATIVE SCIENTIFICHAS BEEN P
HOWNr: AND,  OCUSING ONCE
AGAIN ONSE CHARGEDAPPEALS TOHIU.
THE P TWEETING, I'M
HAPPY TO INFORMF THE LIVING THE
DREAM THAT YOU WILL NOLO
HURT BAV LOW-INCOME
HOUSING BUILT I